NEXT.
♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
ONE THING YOU CAN SAY ABOUT
THE LEFT, THEY DO GET HIGH
MARKS FOR MESSAGE
DISCIPLINE.
SOME FUNCTIONARY IN THE
PROPAGANDA DEPARTMENT COMES
UP WITH A TALKING POINT AND
IMMEDIATELY THE ENTIRE HERD
FROM SENIOR DEMOCRATS IN THE
UNITED STATES SENATE TO
WEEKEND ANCHORS ON MSNBC AND
EVERYONE IN BETWEEN ALL OF
THEM SHAMELESSLY REPEATED IN
VERBATIM LIKE IT'S AN
ORIGINAL THOUGHT.
HAVE YOU HEARD A LOT OF
LINES LIKE THAT.
ONE OF THEM YOU HAVE HEARD A
LOT RECENTLY IS ABOUT DONALD
TRUMP AND THE LAW.
THE PRESIDENT, DEMOCRATS
WILL TELL YOU AGAIN AND
AGAIN, BELIEVES HE IS,
QUOTE, ABOVE THE LAW.
>> WE HAVE A PRESIDENT WHO
BELIEVES IS HE ABOVE THE
LAW.
>> THE AMERICAN PEOPLE DO
NOT WANT A PRESIDENT WHO
BELIEVES THAT HE IS ABOVE
THE LAW.
>> IN THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA, NO ONE IS ABOVE THE
LAW.
>> AN AMERICAN PRESIDENT WHO
HAS NO RESPECT FOR THE RULE
OF LAW.
>> NO ONE IS ABOVE THE LAW.
>> WHAT I WILL SAY IS THAT
NO ONE OUGHT TO BE ABOVE THE
LAW.
>> NO ONE IS ABOVE THE LAW.
NOT EVEN THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Tucker: NO ONE IS ABOVE
THE LAW, THEY THUNDER,
EXCEPT OF COURSE FOR THE
MORE THAN 20 MILLION FOREIGN
NATIONALS CURRENTLY LIVING
IN OUR COUNTRY ILLEGALLY ALL
UNDER THE CARE AND THE
PROTECTION OF THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY.
THEY ARE, BY DEFINITION,
ABOVE THE LAW.
WE CAN'T PUNISH THEM
DEMOCRATS TELL US, THAT
WOULD BE RACIST.
DRUG DEALERS, TOO THEY'RE
SUDDENLY ABOVE THE LAW AS
WELL.
ACCORDING TO THE LEFT.
SO ARE PEOPLE WHO DEFECATE
ON SIDEWALKS AND PEOPLE WHO
SPRAY PAINT OVERPASSES AND
SHOOT UP IN SUBWAY STATIONS
AND LEAVE DIRTY NEEDLES IN
PARK.
ALL CRIMES ALLOWED TO
ACKNOWLEDGE AS CRIMES.
HUMAN CLASSES OF PEOPLE WHO
ARE LITERALLY ABOVE THE LAW.
AND THIS CATEGORY IS GROWING
THANKS TO THE ACTIVIST LEFT.
JUST LAST NIGHT IN THE STATE
OF VIRGINIA, PROSECUTORS
BACKED BY GEORGE SOROS
UNSEEDED INCUMBENTS IN TWO
LARGE COUNTIES OUTSIDE OF
WASHINGTON, D.C.
BOTH CANDIDATES HAVE PLEDGED
TO ROLL BACK CRIMINAL
ENFORCEMENT IN A MASSIVE
WAY.
THEY WILL, AMONG OTHER
THINGS, ABOLISH CASH BAIL,
STOP ENFORCING DRUG LAWS,
PUT MORE CRIMINALS BACK ON
THE STREET.
THIS KIND OF THING IS
HAPPENING ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY.
GETTING VERY LITTLE
COVERAGE.
IN PHILADELPHIA, THE MURDER
RATE IS THE HIGHEST IT HAS
BEEN IN A DECADE.
WHY IS THAT?
WELL, A SOROS BACKED
PROSECUTOR CALLED LARRY
CAUSENER STOPPED ENFORCING
THE LAW.
LEFT WING D.A. IN DALLAS
ANNOUNCED HE WILL STOP
PROSECUTING PEOPLE FOR MOST
KINDS OF THEFT.
IN DALLAS, THIEVES ARE NOW
ABOVE THE LAW.
BETO O'ROURKE APPROVES OF
THIS TREND.
NOT ONLY SHOULD WE LEGALIZE
MARIJUANA, BETO SAYS, WE
OUGHT TO RETROACTIVELY
EXPUNGE THE CRIMINAL RECORDS
OF EVERYONE WHO BROKE THE
LAW WHILE IT EXISTED.
>> WE ABSOLUTELY NEED
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM AN
AN END TO THE WAR ON DRUGS.
AND END TO THE PROHIBITION
ON MARIJUANA AND EXPUNGEMENT
OF THE ARREST RECORD OF
EVERYONE CAUGHT FOR
POSSESSION OF MARIJUANA.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Tucker: HOW MUCH WOULD
YOU BET BY NEXT YEAR BAITED
TOE WILL BE TELLING US THAT
DRUG DEALERS DESERVE
REPARATIONS FROM THE REST OF
US.
ACTUALLY WE ARE NOT JUST
GUESSING ABOUT THAT.
SOME ON THE LEFT ARE ALREADY
DEMANDING REPARATIONS FOR
DRUG DEALERS.
DEMOCRATS ARE SO EAGER TO
REORDER OUR JUSTICE SYSTEM
YOU MIGHT IMAGINE THAT
CRIMINALS ARE DRIVING THE
AGENDA AND OF COURSE THAT'S
PART OF THE PLAN, TOO,
LITERALLY.
BERNIE SANDERS SAYS IT'S
TIME TO LET VIOLENT FELONS
VOTE FROM PRISON.
>> WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THE
RIGHT TO VOTE THE RIGHT
SHOULD EXIST FOR PEOPLE WHO
ARE CURRENTLY IN JAIL THAT
IS A RIGHT WE MUST PROTECT
BECAUSE WE KNOW THE HISTORY
OF THIS COUNTRY.
WE KNOW THAT WOMEN DIDN'T
HAVE THE RIGHT TO VOTE.
WE KNOW AFRICAN-AMERICANS
DIDN'T HAVE THE RIGHT TO
VOTE.
>> UNLESS MURDERERS AND RAPE
ITSESTS CAN ELECT PEOPLE
FROM BEHIND BARS WE ARE BACK
TO SLAVERY THAT'S WHAT
BERNIEY TELLS US.
IT'S HARD TO KNOW HOW TO
RESPOND TO AN ARGUMENT
STUPID.
IT'S AN ATTEMPT TO WIN
VOTES.
WHAT YOU ARE WATCHING FROM
THE LEFT IS REALLY AN ATTACK
ON SOCIETY ITSELF.
THE BASIC BARGAIN IN ANY
SOCIETY IS STRAIGHTFORWARD.
PEOPLE WHO FOLLOW THE RULES
GET REWARDED.
PEOPLE WHO DON'T GET
PUNISHED.
IF YOU GET RID OF THAT
STANDARD, THEN EVERYTHING
INVESTORS.
SUDDENLY POWER FLOWS TO THE
WORST PEOPLE IN YOUR
SOCIETY.
THE MOST RUTHLESS AND
AGGRESSIVE.
DECENT, LAW ABIDING PEOPLE,
MEANWHILE ARE MOCKED.
JUST SUCKERS WHO CAN BE
EXPLOITED BY EVERYONE ELSE.
THAT'S WHERE YOU GET --
THAT'S WHERE WE ARE HEADING
BY THE WAY AND FAST.
'S IT'S PRETTY OBVIOUS WHEN
YOU LOOK AROUND.
>> THE THREADS ARE FRAYING.
IT'S COMING APART.
HUNDREDS OF YEARS OF HARD
WORK AND SELF-DISCIPLINE
DESIGNED TO CREATE WHAT WE
USED TO CALL CIVILIZATION
BEFORE THE TERM CIVILIZATION
WAS DEEMED RACIST.
PEOPLE DOING THIS TO US
WON'T HAVE TO LIVE WITH THE
CONS SEQUENCES OF IT.
THAT'S THEIR GUESS.
THEIR DECK CAN'T MORONS WHO
NEVER LIVED IN A TOUGH
NEIGHBORHOOD.
UNFORTUNATELY THEY ARE NOW